[Music]
I'm a devops engineer or at least a
developer responsible for making sure
containerized workloads are chugging
along smoothly and I want to make sure
my microservices are ready to go on top
of Google kubernetes engine let's see
how du can help to get a good
understanding of the services I'm
managing I want to look at the logs and
find out what's going on I can ask du AI
from inside Google Cloud console and
with enough context it gives me back
answer I can copy and paste into Cloud
logging once I've gotten some of the
logs results from that search query I'd
like to better understand them in
addition to the chat in the sidebar duet
AI can explain queries to help me see
what these results will include and give
me better insight into my
workloads to make sure the new test
deployment I'm building out stays out of
view of the public I'd like to create a
private build environment nobody on the
internet should be able to see the Half
Baked stuff I'm testing with or we might
get some bad public listening du AI is
here to help once more in addition to
documentation about private pools with
Cloud build it can give me the gcloud
commands I need to create them and away
we go ah not so fast I need a config
file to specify some of those
identifiers and parameters to AI is
ready to help here again so I'll just
make my own file using the guidance I
received and double check can I skip
some of those options because there are
default
values yes yes I can
yay once that file is done I'm ready to
try the g-cloud command once more using
the configuration I just set
up so I have a build pool but what about
the packages I want in my private pool a
quick query shows me that I can use
artifact registry to host my packages
and with a private repo I'm ready to go
just follow du a g-cloud guidance and
I'm set almost do I need to fill in the
KMS key parameter nope easy peasy lemon
squeezy I'll run that command create the
repo and my workers are ready this is
great I got help from d a on gke setup
logs analysis private test deployments
and private package hosting check out
the link in the description to learn
more about how you can be productive in
Google Cloud using du
[Music]
aai